and Tinie Tempah joins me now hello to
you and don't ever I don't know how much
you could hear of Marsha rig but I just
wanted to get your response to what she
had to say of the death of her her
brother Sean and the memories that have
been brought back as she saw that
footage of George Floyd yeah just some
rest in peace - Sean Regan condolences
to his family I only could have end of
what she was saying but of course you
know where were all hurting right now
over the death of George Floyd and the
circumstance was Sean rig well all those
years ago is not not that different so
you know my condolences when you saw the
video what was your response well my
response was like anyone elses I was I
was disgusted I was outraged and you
know unfortunately for me this is not
the first video I've seen like this so
there's there's been dozens and dozens
of videos that have come out of America
over the recent years
falando Cass bill included Eric garner
included which was a very similar
situation to George fluid so yeah I just
for me I I can't even really describe my
emotions and words and so yeah I just I
just wanted to vent my frustration
through lyrics and of course you know I
did my my own personal bits of why I
could to help you know directly to black
lives matter or what not but yes been
going on for too long and it isn't just
in our lifetime it's been going on long
before us you know this is a systemic
problem racism isn't only going on in
America you know the UK is not innocent
Europe is not innocent you know this is
a systemic thing that is not only within
the police institutions and other
institutions as well so you know being
black you can't not watch that video and
Phil you know a deep deep pain that that
there's no real way of healing you
tweeted and how many times does this
need to happen in America till all the
African Americans with power global
influence and immense wealth do
something
to make these unjust crimes stop
happening for good how many videos must
the world watch this is going on in the
supposedly and of the free do something
what do you want to be done I mean I
don't necessarily have the answer I
think when I tweeted that I was tweeting
out of frustration you know because the
illusion that's painted to us of what
America is like is almost like this
prosperous place where you can you can
go and drive and kind of become
everything you want but you know when
you're looking at the majority of the
population and how they're living even
you know in reference to you know Cove
in 19 and the the deaths that had been
going on there the deaths that have been
going on here you know double the amount
of our counterparts I think for me I was
almost looking to my icons into my
legends you know people that had grown
up you know watching even though the
majority of them have done amazing
things to raise awareness of racism you
know police brutality this disease that
is racism I think for me because I kind
of felt helpless you know I was kind of
looking to the people who I felt were
powerful that were kind of within my
eyeline and it was them but in terms of
that the overall answer it's obviously a
lot more complicated than that and in
terms of the response of people with
power what do you make of the way
President Trump has handled this I mean
I definitely feel like the the tear
gassing of individuals the rubber
bullets being used on individuals I
definitely think that that's not the way
forward I think this is not the first
time it's happened you know so people
have been rioting and prote and
protesting and uprising you know lack
was previously said time and time again
this has been happening so I feel like
yeah you go and going back and using
tear gas on innocent people rubber
bullets on innocent people is not a way
to send a world a message of unity
against this injustice that is you know
the death of George Floyd what does
justice for George Floyd look like again
you know I am NOT here claiming to have
all of the answers you know I was
thrilled and relieved to hear that
Derrick Chauvin who was the police
officer who you know you know committed
that unjust evil act you know III don't
know how I'll spare to describe it I was
thrilled and relieved and there was
almost like a mini bit of justice when
we when we learned that he had been
convicted and he'd been charged with
murder as well and so I'm sure that
again I couldn't even put myself in the
shoes of George Flo's family but I'm
sure that they would be also very happy
to hear that as well but you know like I
said it's deeper than just George Road
you know everybody you know of color
everybody within this kind of like black
and ethnic minority the Bain community
all over the world feels the effects of
racism you know we all feel it the same
it's just it's just that you know and
and to think sorry that you know the
people that are protecting you can be
your murderers you know is even a bit
more of a scarier feeling so yeah I
guess justice for George bridge would be
Derrick Chauvin and all of the other
officers that were around as well
because some of them haven't been named
yet for all of those people to be held
account for all of those people to be
jailed but again you know there's a
bigger issue and now that we all have
these platforms to talk you know I just
want to say that the world is a racist
place you know we we the our system that
we're in is a white racist oppressive
system and until people can kind of look
up and acknowledge this and come
together to make change you know change
definitely does not happen overnight but
this has been going on for the last four
or five hundred years you go mean and in
in our timeline that we can reference
the last 60 70 years since a lot of
these countries have been liberated and
free so I think it's time for everybody
to kind of like identify the white
elephant in the room and just come
together to start finding some real
solutions of how we can eradicate such a
primitive disease do you think when you
see the movements the protests going on
in Hyde Park today the black lives
matter movement
black out Tuesday yesterday and the
response to that that we are at a point
when we are starting to see some change
or at least the appetite for that change
I feel like I feel like social media is
definitely giving us almost a magnifying
glass into the emotions and the feeling
of the world and there's definitely been
a great tool to you not one another you
know because for me this is the first
one of the first real times that I've
seen a real you know diverse palette of
people stand out openly against this
injustice you know with with all the
different levels of profiles that they
have so I definitely feel like this
protest is has been great for raising
awareness but you know at the same time
it hasn't ended the problem and so we
need to even continue this conversation
beyond this to find some real solutions
okay Tinie Tempah thanks very much
indeed for talking to us here on Sky
News thank you